How do you rate yourself on a scale of
one to 10 in terms of your physical
appearance and turns of your hell?
Do you take care of yourself?
Are you allowing yourself to get
overweight and out of shape?
Are you conscious of your health?
Are you watching the food that you take
into your body?
Do you make a deliberate effort to
exercise?
You know it was George Burns is that we
cannot help getting older,
but we don't have to get old and many of
us get old before our time because we
don't take time to take care of
ourselves.
Your environment is a very good
indicator.
On a scale of one to 10 is it what you
want it to be?
Do you find it desirable?
Are you satisfied the job or career that
you're involved in?
Someone said that 85% of the American
public are unhappy with their jobs.
Are you spending eight hours a day just
doing time,
doing something that you don't find
challenging,
that does not make you stretch mentally,
but does not stimulate you?
That does not inspire you?
Something that you don't find a sense of
fulfillment in it.
If you're doing that day in and day out,
it has to affect how you feel about
yourself,
your level of motivation,
your relationships.
What kind of impact is that having on
your life?
Is it nourishing or is it if toxic
relationship,
does it drain you or does it build you
up?
Ask yourself that.
How motivated are you to do something
about it?
Your contribution,
your actions?
What are you giving?
Many people will leave the universe
without a trace.
No one will know they were here and in
fact under their name we can put under
there not used up.
Yeah.
Well,
anybody know that you came this way?
What contribution are you giving?
What will you leave?
What will be different because you came
this way.
Someone once said that life is our gift
to us that God has given us and how we
live our lives is our gift to God.
What kind of gift are you formulating?
Is this a gift that you like to take
back and do something else before you
turn it in?
Think about that.
What can we do?
What are some of the keys that we can
begin to use to motivate ourselves when
our battery's running low?
Because I don't care who you are.
I don't care what you do at sometime you
are going to get tired at certain time.
You're going to get in a Rut,
seem like nothing you do works out
right.
And sometimes it just seems like you
just don't have the wherewithal or the
will to do anything.
That's,
sometimes you act like you're punch
drunk.
You're just wading through life.
Just doing time,
day in and day out,
looking at nondiscriminatory television,
anything that's all just looking
okay
and depress,
feeling powerless,
feeling useless and both.
What do you do?
How do you get yourself out of a Rut?
How do you,
when you know you can do more of and
what you've been doing and you're not
doing it and you're discontent with
where you are,
you get angry at yourself.
How do you get out of that Rut?
How do you motivate yourself?
One of the things that we must do is
that we must be involved and working on
achieving self mastery.
You must work on yourself continuously.
Never be satisfied with yourself.
Always know that as you invest the
effort and time on you,
that's the greatest ability that human
beings have above animals.
See,
a dog can be anything but a dog.
Three can be anything but a tree.
Human being.
You've got unlimited potential.
You can put effort on you and by
concentrating on you and developing you,
you can transform your life wherever you
are right now.
So you want to work on yourself.
You want to read books that inspire you
and motivate you.
You want to listen to tapes over and
over and over again,
and I suggest that you listen to tapes.
When you first get up in the morning,
you want to control the spirit of your
day.
When you first wake up in the morning,
your mind is operating at 10.5 wave
cycles per second.
That's when the subconscious mind is
most impressionable.
Whatever you hear in the first 20
minutes when you wake up,
that will affect the spirit of your day.
When you're listening to tapes,
listen with relaxed belief,
believing that this can happen for you
and by listening to them,
listen to them over and over and over
again and you'll get a breakthrough.
You can listen to the same tape for
months and all of a sudden you're here.
Something you'd never heard before.
It have a special meaning for you or
read the same book over again and you'll
find some special inside.
You said,
I can't believe I didn't see that the
first time.
So you want to be involved and
developing yourself.
Most people won't do that.
Most people won't take that kind of
effort and invest that kind of energy in
themselves because they will fall prey
to that conversation within,
Oh,
don't do that.
You don't have time.
You're too busy.
You're too caught up in the rat race.
Most people won't do that.
What?
They won't take time to go to lectures.
They want to take time to go to
seminars.
They won't take time to go to classes to
improve themselves,
and as you continue to work on yourself,
you will begin to expand your vision of
yourself.
You begin to work towards self mastery.
Yeah.
And you will begin to see it reflect
itself in all the dimensions of your
life,
your mental life,
your physical life,
your social life in your relationships,
your monetary life.
Concentrate on developing yourself.
Okay.
Because if you don't,
I guarantee you that you will make a
settlement.
And most people have,
and most of us already have.
What kind of settlement have you made
with your life?
You know,
when we make settlements out of court
settlements,
you've heard them.
That means that you to take something
less than what you originally wanted to
get had you gone into court.
And the reason that you settle outside
of court is because you didn't believe
that you can get it.
So you made an out of court settlement.
Many of us I'm making in life settlement
with settling for less than what we
actually deserve.
We don't feel good about it,
but we make it work in our minds.
We'll come up with some kind of excuse
to make it all right.
What kind of settlement have you made
with your life?
Many of us settle for less than what we
want out of relationships because we
don't have the courage to change them.
I had a seminar I used to do call.
Are you living together or dine
together?
Many people are just dying together.
Gladys Knight used to have a song that
says neither one of us want to be the
first to say good
bye.
The next thing is in order to begin to
find some keys to self motivation to
drive yourself.
In addition to working on yourself and
as you work on yourself,
you feel good about yourself and as you
feel better about yourself,
you treat yourself differently.
Develop a health plan so you can't feel
well and do well.
If you don't have good health,
you can't perform.
If you don't have your health,
your health is valuable.
Develop a health plan,
a plan that you will follow because this
is the only vehicle that you have to
carry you through this experience called
life and you want to take good care of
it because you love you or not.
You care enough about you and that's not
easy.
It is not easy.
Having a health plan and sticking to it,
but you're worth it.
Doing it again and again and again.
I have lost 22 pounds several times.
Yeah,
separate.
It's,
I'll always do it.
I love potato chips.
People who know me know I love m and M,
peanuts.
I love peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches.
I love my mother Sweet Potato Pie.
I love this.
It's not always on my health plan,
but I put it on there sometimes.
I said,
life is too short to go without sweet
potato pie.
If I go to night,
I want you to slip on supplies and sweet
potato pie.
My cats get up and watch the smile.
Oh,
by phase
maximizing is as you take care of
yourself.
The next key is keys to motivation to
self motivation.
You want to live life with energy and
passion.
You want to make a conscious effort to
be lively.
See Him live.
You either saying hello or goodbye.
You either own the way or in the way
lead that people alone.
Some folk just walking around looking,
how are you doing honey?
Stay away from these people that has
gone away from them and affects you.
You want to smile,
you want to be happy.
You got a lot to be thankful for,
but you watch some of the faces around
you every day
and I tell you some of these faces,
they will put you in a depressed state
of mind,
so you want to avoid these kinds of
faces when you see them coming.
Turn your head.
Next thing is that you want to monitor
your inner conversations.
The things that you say to yourself.
You want to watch them and then watching
them.
You want to take charge.
Friend of mine told me this evening as
she did it excellently,
she said,
I didn't want to come tonight.
I was feeling so depressed and I said,
I'm going in anyhow.
See if that was the conversations that,
oh,
you really don't feel like it.
You really don't need to do it.
You don't really need to read anything.
Forget all that.
That's that inner conversation.
Oh,
you don't need to worry about trying to
go into your own business.
Forget that you can't do that.
What have you lose everything.
You've got that in the conversation that
stopped you from doing the things you
want to do less.
Don't do that.
How can you possibly think about being a
motivational speaker?
You don't have the contacts.
You don't have the money.
You don't know the right people.
You're going to get up there and your
mind's going to go blank.
Forget all that.
You remember that time you got up before
some people and you're panicked.
You stood up in your mind,
set down,
don't you remember?
And I said yes.
And then I said Shit Up.
So you got to learn to stand up to
yourself inside yourself and short
circuit override that conversation.
That's always going on.
85% of what that conversation will tell
you is negative.
It's negative.
It will tell you you're tied.
When you really are not tired.
It will tell you you can't do it.
It will fill you with fear.
So you've got to watch that conversation
and when you find that going on,
you've got to stand up to it and said,
I'm going to do this anyhow.
I'm afraid,
but I'm afraid not to do it and I'm not
going to let you stop me.
The biggest challenge that you will have
in life is you.
It's an old African proverb that says
this,
there's no enemy within the enemy
outside can do us no harm.
The next thing that is a key to self
motivation is that you've got to ask
yourself,
what do I want out of life?
What do you want out of life?
What do you want out of a job?
What do you want out of career?
What do want out of a relationship?
What do you want?
What gives you your life?
How many of you know when you got it,
what will make you happy?
You'll need to know.
You need to start asking yourself some
questions.
What do I really,
really,
truly want?
Okay?
Do you need to be exact about that?
Don't be vague.
Oh,
I just want to be happy.
That's too vague.
What will make you happy?
How will you know when you got it?
Zero in on it.
Be Exact.
Be specific.
And as you do that,
that will stimulate that superconscious
mind or the reticular activating system
of your mind that will begin to find
those things to identify with it.
Yeah,
and once you begin to determine that
which you want,
take the time to write it down.
Don't just think about it.
Write it down.
That is a subjective process that
engages the subconscious mind.
Write it down.
Once you write it down,
read it three times a day,
morning,
noon,
and night was that important because
what it will do,
it will cost you to focus.
It will cause you to concentrate when
that other conversation is going on,
telling you what you cannot do,
telling you all of the impossibilities
and all of the obstacles you're
concentrating will begin to create a
larger vision within yourself and you'll
start looking for and seeing some new
opportunities.
You start creating some openings for
yourself as you begin to read that
everyday,
day in and day out.
That will make you focus,
that will discipline your Thanki and
you'll get all kinds of creative ideas.
As I talked to you right now,
being involved in this immersion
process,
you're going to create some openings for
yourself.
You're going to get some ideas,
you've got to feel your gym and flowing,
and you're going to think about
something.
Some idea you had,
you said,
I want to go back and I'm going to look
at that again from a different vantage
point.
Not from the level of the problem of the
obstacles that I encountered,
but if from a higher vantage point,
because what?
You will begin to see him to know as I
have talked to the higher consciousness
within you,
but you are powerful that you are a
miracle worker.
And that inner conversation has
conditioned you to believe that you not.
And as you begin to discover the truth
of who you are,
whatever challenge that you're facing in
life,
and if you're living,
you're facing some challenge,
you'll begin to know that you are
powerful and that your America maker.
So as you begin to write down exactly
what it is that you want,
read it every day.
The next thing is see yourself there.
How will you feel once you get there?
What will the experience be like for
you?
What will be different?
What kind of person do you have to
become in to get there?
Visualize yourself there.
Living the experience.
I remember when I ran for state
representative in Columbus,
Ohio and I had a lot of people telling
me,
and you got to watch not only the
conversation within,
but the conversation without telling me
less.
You can't possibly when you can't do
that,
and I went down to the legislature and I
saw myself.
I knew what I wanted.
I saw myself in the chair.
I pointed out the chair that I wanted.
I used to go in and set up in the
galleries and watch the legislative
process.
I used to go to the committee meetings
and listen to legislation being
introduced.
I learned how to write legislation,
how to amend legislation.
I start thinking like a legislator.
Got Up everyday dressing,
thinking like that,
selling myself on it,
seeing myself in the legislature.
Mr Speaker,
I'm the gentleman from the 29th house
district.
I'd like to introduce the bill.
I went into the legislature,
walked around,
I have the experience of it,
okay?
And when I ran and won against
overwhelming odds,
they were shocked.
I won the election even before it was
hell because I was living it in my mind.
You want to see yourself beyond your
circumstances.
You got to challenge.
See yourself beyond your challenge.
See yourself with a challenge already
resolved
and knowing that all is well.
Seeing yourself in control and in charge
of your destiny,
being healthy and happy.
The next thing is it is important in the
area of motivating yourself.
It's important to know why you're doing
it,
because that mine will say,
why bother?
Why go through all this?
This is too hard.
No,
throw in the towel.
It's not worth it.
It has it ever said that to you before.
Here's how you can handle that.
Here's how you override that.
Write down five reasons why you deserve
it.
Why do you deserve what you want?
Why are you
okay?
Why do you deserve it?
What meaning and value will it bring to
your life?
What's so different about you that you
deserve your goal or this goal and when
you write down those five reasons,
when you have some down moments and
you're going to have them,
when that conversation started talking
to you and it's going to talk to you,
what you will do is you can pull that
out and read it and it will build you
up.
It will be your rod and your staff to
conferences you through some challenging
moments because you're going to have
some life will knock you between the
eyes.
It will catch you on the blind side.
Come out of nowhere,
Steph,
you can't anticipate that will knock the
wind out of you.
You want to give up.
Okay?
That's why it's important for you to
work on yourself,
listening to tapes,
building yourself up,
talking to yourself with power,
feeling and conviction.
Building yourself up day in and day out
because it's coming.
I guarantee you life is just,
oh,
he's doing good now,
Huh?
Very good.
I've never had an experience.
I was pursuing my dream and that's why
you have to work on yourself.
You don't know what's going to happen
and I was telling people,
I had this big rally I had to do with
5,000 people there and I said,
you must work on yourself if you want a
larger vision,
you've got to empower yourself
continuously because life,
we'll catch you on the blind side.
And after I finished my speech,
I got a rousing standing ovation and I
wouldn't call the young lady that I was
dating at the time.
I said,
hey,
guess what?
I said,
they love me.
I got a standing ovation and they were
chanting,
we want the motivator.
We want the motivator.
I say,
listen,
we want to motivate everyone.
Do your hair.
She said,
yes.
Well that's what I need to talk to you.
I put one item in it.
You're talking about the 12 hours and
I'll be all filled less.
I heard a voice in the background.
Hurry up and tell him who's that
last time you've been gone a lot in then
somebody else and they came in last.
Come on mister motivator.
They want you back out there.
Wait a minute,
hold it.
Hold on.
I'm sorry.
There's someone else in the heard of the
say,
hang the phone up.
I said,
why don't they just say,
hey,
motivated.
Come on.
They want you to catch it.
Ham
share.
When you work it on a larger vision,
I say you,
you got to really work on yourself.
Can Light.
We'll catch you on the blind side.
You Bet.
Show
this.
Nobody said the spirit is on.
In fact,
if I define device,
I was told to tell us not blinking the
lights.
They had the cup put me off,
but I said,
you got to have a larger,
you make show you work.
I said,
come on.
Listen Brown Chabot.
Yeah,
I would to my hotel room and loneliness
and heartbreak was sitting on the bed,
said,
are you coming in now?
Huh?
Do you have your larger vision now?
How's your positive attitude they get on
in yet?
Are you still breathing shut?
Shut up.
Nope.
You want your gold?
[inaudible] gold,
Donald
[inaudible].
Well,
you out.
You'll be said,
no,
I didn't know how hard
you try to read it.
Get C.
Dot.
Do the tiers.
I would plug in through the draws in his
hotel trying to find a Gideon Bible.
Anything I said,
somebody,
anybody,
he'll be y'all where y'all who entered
by flow.
That's why you got to work on yourself.
Could live.
We'll send you some curves you cannot
anticipate.
The next thing is that whatever you do,
you want to develop technical mastery.
You want to be the best at what you do.
You want to master it.
See,
part of of of self motivation is you've
got to find something that gives you a
strong sense of competence.
When you've become known for that,
you develop a reputation of being good
at doing that.
You set some high personal standards for
yourself.
You're not competing with anybody else.
You're just unfolding yourself to be the
best person that you could be,
that you want to give the best quality
service that you can give because that
is a statement about who you are.
The other thing that's the key to self
motivation is recognize the fact that
you're going to get into some slumps.
Recognize the fact that you're going to
encounter a great deal of failure in
life and goes with the territory,
but in the face of that,
you want to be relentless and when you
want something,
you can don't expect everybody to say,
oh,
come on in.
We've been,
Oh,
you want this?
Oh great,
we want to give this to you.
You're such a nice person.
You're doing it for your family.
Aren't you gray?
I don't like this.
And like that,
no many doors will be closed in your
face.
Many loans that you will want and they
say,
no,
you don't have enough collateral.
You don't have enough credit,
and most people will give up,
but you've got to decide that I'm going
to be fearless.
I refuse to be tonight and I'm going to
go all out.
I'm going to be relentless.
I don't care how many no's I
encountered.
I liked something.
Isaiah,
as Thomas said,
when it's getting ready for a basketball
game,
he said,
I'm going to either shoot us in or shoot
us out,
but I'm not going to not do anything.
And that's the way to go.
You can't make a basket unless you shoot
the ball.
You can't hit a home run unless you take
a swing at it.
Most people won't even take a slang.
Well,
I probably won't make it anyhow.
That's the conversation with him.
They probably won't give it to me
anyhow.
If you want something,
you've got to be relentless.
You've got to decide I deserve this and
I'm going to have it,
and you go all out to get it.
That drives you.
The next thing is that when you want
something out of life,
you've got to be willing to go into
action.
Don't wait around for things to be just
right.
Don't wait for things to be perfect.
Don't wait for the ideal situation.
It will never be ideal.
There will always be a reason.
As soon as the children grow up,
oh,
soon as I pay my bills,
well soon as I get my divorce time,
as soon as I get enough money together,
do what you can,
where you are with what you have and
never be satisfied.
A lot of people never take a chance in
life.
They don't want to take any chances.
They want the situation to be ideal.
That would say that's not walking by
faith.
That's walking by sight.
If I can see it,
I'll do it.
No,
no,
no glass.
A lot of people say,
if I can see it,
I believe it.
No,
no,
no.
If you believe it,
you can see it
and
don't be disturbed because no one else
can see it.
That's not unusual.
That is ordinary,
but because you want some different
kinds of results in your life,
you've got to be willing to be
unreasonable.
If you weren't on reasonable results in
your life,
you've got to be willing to be on
reasonable pot of being unreasonable.
You don't judge according to
appearances,
Potter being unreasonable.
You can see it because you believe it.
That's part of being unreasonable.
Potter being unreasonable.
You're like Paulo said,
you must have the faith to call forth
those things that be not as though they
were as part of being unreasonable.
Most people won't do that.
Most people say,
call me when you get it together,
then I'll support you.
The other thing is that what are the
keys to stuff?
Motivation that empower you is that you
want to find a cause larger than
yourself.
Find something that you can contribute
to.
Find something that you can make a
difference because you can,
part of what feeds your larger vision,
part of what gives you a reason for
being part of what gives you your life
is being able to give something back so
I can't afford to give anything you
can't afford not to give.
Give your time,
give your talent is nothing just to go
over and lick envelopes.
I don't know exactly what I'm going to
do,
but I'm going over there.
It's part of my tithing in the universe.
Once you develop that,
that special sense of mission and that's
what you develop when you're part of a
larger cause,
then yourself,
it drives you.
You don't need an alarm clock to get up
in the morning.
You have special power.
You'll go places and folk will like to
be around you.
They will know there's something
different about you.
When you go in there say,
hey,
that's somebody important.
I want to know who you are.
I just want to be near you.
That energy that you have,
that consciousness that you will embody
will affect everybody around you.
The next thing is is that you want to
create a home court advantage for
yourself.
You've got to be aware of who you have
around you,
so you want to be selective.
Have friends that will enable use of
grow.
I have friends that help me to grow
spiritually.
These are my spiritual friends.
I talked spiritual stuff with them.
I have some other friends who are just
intellectual friends.
They make me grow intellectually.
They make me stretch.
I have some professional friends.
I'm a member of the National Speakers
Association.
I get together with other speakers and
we learn from each other and we grow
from each other.
I have other friends who are just social
friends.
All we do just socialize together.
We are looking at a basketball game
together or go out dancing,
but that's all we can do.
We don't talk anything serious,
nothing spiritual,
nothing intellectual.
That's not that kind of relationship.
Nothing heavy up in here.
Have other friends.
We walked together,
that's all we can do.
Walk together talking about it.
We're going to lose weight one day,
buying vine for good.
All right?
That's all we do.
Nothing else.
So according to the relationships that
you develop,
we grow from people and projects and the
relationships that you develop.
Kenton Hanson can enrich your life or
they can drain you.
I know many talented people who had a
great deal of potential,
but because they didn't surround
themselves with other people that will
inspire them to transcend themselves,
they never realize that greatness and
they will end up going to their grave
with all their good stuff still in him.
So you want to look at your
relationships,
the people that you're involved with,
the people that you communicate with
most often,
and you want to ask yourself the
question,
what am I becoming because of this
relationship?
Does it inspire me?
Am I motivated?
Am I encourage?
Am I driven to develop myself?
Am I seeking my own greatness?
What kind of person am I becoming
because of this relationship?
Okay?
Am I becoming more cynical and negative
about life?
Ask yourself that.
The next thing is you've got to say yes
to your life.
You've got to say yes.
Okay?
Yes to my dreams,
yes to me.
Yes,
I can make it.
I can.
Doesn't matter how many failures I've
made,
doesn't matter how many mistakes I've
been endured.
Doesn't matter about my defeats.
Doesn't matter about what I've done.
Yes.
Okay.
I don't care about the fact that I'm in
a hole now.
Doesn't matter about where I am.
Yes.
The last chapter to my life has not been
written yet.
If you judge me now,
your judge Mi prematurely,
I haven't exposed all my stuff yet.
I'm still in the process of transforming
my life.
I'm still in the process of becoming.
Okay.
Yes.
I had somebody in my life at one time
told me,
you are never made,
and I said,
I'll show you what energizes me.
What motivated me was something that
Frank Sinatra said.
He said,
the best revenge is massive success.
[inaudible]
you just watch my smoke as old folks
still say yes.
Stand up for your dreams.
Stand up for what you want in your life.
Decide that your life is so meaningful
to you,
that you love you and you love life so
much,
you're going to stand up for something
you want.
I used to have a saying when I was on
the radio stands up for what you believe
in because you can fall for anything.
So when I say to you this evening that
you are powerful,
you have miracle working power in your
life right now,
but you've got to work on yourself.
You've got to develop yourself.
You've got to talk to yourself day in
and down,
selling yourself on you and on your
potentials,
and you've got to know that,
that you are worth all of your effort
and that the key to your motivation as
you'll get a larger vision of yourself,
is to know that you have something to
give,
is to know that you have a reason for
being in the universe at this point in
time.
I want you to stand up for your life
right now.
Anybody want to stand up for your up?
Be Your dream standing up for your
dreams.